there are currently three main types
of kobe 19 vaccines that are either
licensed and recommended for use in
the us or being studied in
large-scale clinical trials in the
us each vaccine causes a person's body to
recognize and protect against the
virus with 19  it is important to remember that
none of these vaccines can give
a person b19 or b19 some vaccines against
kobe 19 require one dose and others
require two doses if the vaccine you
received requires two doses you will need to
receive both doses of the vaccine to
be fully vaccinated and protected
against kobe 19 let's go over the three
different types of vaccines kobe 19 the first
type of vaccine we'll talk about is an
mma vaccine the m&r enea vaccine contains material
from the kobe 19 virus that instructs
the body's cells on how to
make a harmless protein that  it is
exclusive to the kobe 19 virus
once the cells produce copies of this
protein they destroy the genetic material
from the vaccine a person's body will
recognize that the protein shouldn't
be there and will form special white blood cells
to fight the virus these
special cells called lymphocytes
this and lymphocytes will remind you how to
fight the virus
if the person gets committees and 9 in the
future the  second type of vaccine we
will talk about is a protein subunit vaccine
this type of vaccine includes
harmless parts called proteins
of the virus that cause kobe 19 instead of the
whole virus once a person
receives this type of vaccine their
immune system recognizes that the  proteins
do not belong to the body
and it begins to produce lymphocytes and
antibodies
if a person ever gets kobe
19 in the future the memory cells
will recognize and fight the virus
the third type of vaccine we will talk about
is a vectorial vaccine this type of
vaccine contains  a modified version
of a different virus than the one that causes kobe
inside the capsule of  he
modified virus contains material from the
virus that causes as of 19 this is called
a viral vector once the viral vector is
inside the cells of the body the
genetic material instructs the
cells to produce a protein that
is exclusive to the virus that  causes
copper 19 with these instructions
cells make copies of the protein
that causes the body to develop
t cells p cells that will remember how to
fight copy 19 virus if a person
gets kobe 19 in the future let's review
what we just discussed and review
some  of the key points
there are currently three main types of
kobe 19 vaccines that are either licensed and
recommended for use in the us
or being studied in
large scale clinical trials in the us
none of these vaccines can give kobe
19 to 1
all three  types of vaccines are
mrn vaccines to protein subunit
vaccines vector vaccines
[Music]